juri tschaika mal kurz rein
wir machen gerade diese challenge und
mit dem anschreiben
marie hat gerade vorgeschrieben eine
minute später hatte hey leute was gehabt
hätte bekommen bei 9 video okay so sieht
das aber wie das ist echt mein mann
sieht das doch da unten
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja ich hoffe
natürlich euch hier das haushaltsrecht
ist aber nicht nackt alter du hast jeden
hast du mir also nicht obwohl jetzt
geht's los der sag ich doch genau so
erzählt es nicht mehr so witzig mal
wieder so jetzt gehen wir so nah so ist
eigentlich am besten leute im heutigen
video machen wir was nicht besonderes
weil es gibt schon 10.000 mal wir
springen praktisch auf ein training auf
aber ich muss sagen ich habe diesen
trend etwas auf uns angepasst und ein
bisschen so weiter nachlasse und zwar
wahrscheinlich schon sehr viele videos
gesehen wo irgendwelche youtuber
irgendwelche promis stars berühmtheiten
wie man auch immer will anschreiben und
dann schauen wer von diesen ganzen
leuten eigentlich bei instagram
antworten und maria das vorgeschlagen
dass wir das auch machen sollen und dann
habe ich so gedacht ja kann man mal
machen so aber haben halt schon viele
gemacht und wir machen da heute so ein
kleines geschlechter battle raus weil
man kann ja schon so sagen dass so
männer schon ein bisschen notgelder sind
als doch so da es gibt genug und mädels
die nach dem blauen haken
[Musik]
nochmal ich würde sagen dass viele
männer immer mädels anschreiben und
weniger umgekehrt und deswegen
schließlich daraus hast du an sich
glaube ich höre chancen hast es die
leute antworten werden als wenn ich es
irgendwelche girls anschreiben nur da
gebe ich dir völlig recht ich habe einen
blauen haken und das sticht vielleicht
also wir haben halt blöd so auf insider
und das stich glaube ich schon heraus
dann in diesem nach inwiefern sagen okay
wir haben uns jeder 10 rausgesucht wir
haben auch so ein bisschen selber
untereinander abgestimmt wenn man nehmen
kann
sie haben uns zwei regeln gesetzt
mindestens 200.000 abonnenten oder es
ist halt wirklich einen riesen profi so
man sagen muss okay den kennen viele
menschen sowie was haben wir das
beispiel bei dir den wendler
also dieser schlagersänger und sinclair
habe gehört dass steht auf junge mädels
ich fange an meiner liste
deine ok ok chilli david alexis ran
soraya eckes kenne ich nicht aber marie
kenntnis von luna schweiger erkannte ich
jetzt auch nicht ich kannte nur diese
emma schweiger also die töchter von til
schweiger mit bella simone von gntm
diese die das jetzt gewonnen hat
den kenne ich sogar laura müller das ist
die freundin von dem wendler deswegen da
haben wir so gedacht hey komm wir
checken dass man ab beschreiben ich
schreibe die an du schreibst den an
juli also von die rapperin musikerin
katja glaser witsch und cheyenne
ochsenknecht meine liste dass das ist
glaube ich der größte auf meiner liste
daher ich mich auch nicht mit einer
antwort aber weiß ja nie kapital brach
unterbrach pietro lombardi vincent weist
der wendler leona lewis an ist glaube
ich ein fußballspieler kam von mir das
ist auf jeden fall der also lieber
us-armee ist vom bekanntheitsgrad auf
jeden fall der bekannteste in der liste
ok also ab was dem bisher wenig heute
müssen und julian brand genau ja ich
würde sagen du machst jetzt bildschirm
auch mit seinem handy ich auch und dann
schreiben wir die alle an
wir schreiben allen hey wie gehts okay
und wer meint wir haben jetzt mal ich
und dann warten wir bis heute abend
später oder morgen früh und schauen halt
wer gewonnen okay wir schreiben jetzt
erstmal an
[Musik]
oder solche mit diesen mit diesem note
kein smiley machen
das ganze bei katja machen und mal
ich mache einfach bei allen so
[Musik]
also ich muss auch sagen an manchen
stellen ist das echt aber es ist ja noch
für das video ein kleiner test
[Musik]
wendla michael seidling wenn ich mir
jetzt erstmal
[Musik]
sieht er ihn sich bestimmt also was das
finden
[Musik]
ja aber dir deutlich über 10 millionen
oder es immer geben die hier bekomme ich
ja gleich so also ich meine tochter
hatte noch vor einer minute geschrieben
mich lässt also ja eigentlich habe ich
schon verloren ich sage mir wird mir
wird garantiert niemand antworten
nachher bin ich in irgendeiner rapper
verschwörungs band oder so und die
wollen mich alle töten herum
ich weiß nicht ob hey komm mal kurz rein
wir machen hat diese challenge und mit
dem anschreiben maria grad
vorgeschrieben eine minute später tk
tecn ein gut und die er heute einfach
extrem hell wie die wirtin diese novaya
geschrieben und soraya ecke ist das
schreiben so es ist ja mal so peinlich
und ich sage wirklich dass dir noch drei
antworten werden und mir hat keiner
und da ist auch dieser blaue haken
scheißegal mannheim glaub ich nicht 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ja ich habe jetzt zehn
leuten geschrieben
dann würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
irgendwann heute spätabends okay und 40
wollt ihr was geht ab wie schaffst du
mir nicht schlecht danke ja genau
perfekt wir haben jetzt schon sonntag
das video haben wir am donnerstag oder
freitag gestartet und es hat nur
geantwortet dann habe ich so gesagt ja
wenn nur der antwort erst gar nicht
hochladen weil das war schon lustig aber
wir haben gesagt wir brauchen noch ein
bisschen ab vielleicht antwortet noch
jemand und ich will jetzt marie ab und
sie meinte sie hat noch eine böse
überraschung weil noch eine oder mehrere
personen gaben uns haben was echt
richtig krass sein soll ich bin mal
gespannt ob bei mir noch jemand
geantwortet hat das erzähle ich euch
dann auch gleich aber ich glaube sie hat
auf jeden fall gewonnen
vielleicht liegt das auch an meine
minister profil leute ihr müsst haben
wir drauf gehen in like dalassen von
oder lassen vielleicht überzeugt die
mädels einfach noch nicht so an extreme
instagram jetzt folgen
ist gleich okay leute was geht wir sind
jetzt wieder was geht ab das aber gut
zusammen gezogen oder wir sind jetzt
wieder hier zu hause
ich habe mir jetzt abgeholt und jetzt
gibt es die auflösung zu diesem langen
video also wer mehr vorgestern
angefangen oder vorvorgestern und das
wird heute aufgelöst ich habe ja noch
nicht gesagt wie viele leute mir
geantwortet haben und ich weiß dass du
jetzt gleich vom reitplatz wirst du
wirst aus allen wolken gefallen wenn du
warst wie viele leute mir geantwortet
haben leute ich kann euch das super
gerne mal einen denn alter ich bin
selber nicht drauf klage kommen können
ich finde mich alle so cool die leute
und zwar haben mir geantwortet das auch
genau keiner gelesen ich glaube auch
nicht mehr kümmern hat gerd werner
gelesen auch nur ansatzweise als ich lag
hier wirklich jeden morgen und habe auf
mein handy geguckt und war von morgen zu
morgen trauriger dass mir einfach keiner
antwortet man hätte doch wenigstens mal
so hey eigentlich bist du ganz cool aber
ihr mann hat es von mir naja
wahrscheinlich dass kam dabei raus
jetzt würde ich sagen darfst du mir
zeigen wir bei dir geantwortet hat indem
du dein handy einmal holst eine person
hat es zu er schon gesehen weil sie
direkt geantwortet hat also das passende
programm schon drin als erstes bringe
ich euch noch mal kurz ein hat jako
beantwortet du hast ja nicht mehr
geantwortet netterweise ich habe gedacht
so einfach wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr da
bin ich heute noch bestimmt zurück weil
ich dem anderen antworten
und jetzt gehen wir zum anlass und
eltern haben wie viele haben ja noch
höheren deutet eine person noch gut so
viel ist das jetzt auch nicht aber dafür
ist die krasseste person von 1
gewesen okay da ich selbst ja schon
immer drauf
heute ist es ja gut an also ich finde
das wirklich krassen guck mal ich weiß
nicht ob wir alle von euch kennen ein
paar werden ihn wahrscheinlich kennen
alvarez das ist schon was macht ihr denn
eigentlich was kann der kann auch nichts
aus so gut aussehen also ich kenne ihn
halt nur von diesem videos war also sein
leben zeit das sind so reisevideos und
so die finde ich echt nice und er hat
wirklich auf instagram 6,4 millionen
abonnenten damit jetzt auch alle seht
dass das wheel ist wir sind jetzt hier
auf dem jet drauf und jetzt das hat mir
geschrieben
vbi selbst drogen oder was er war in der
nacht wirklich feiern ich war auch in
der nacht feiern leute deswegen habe ich
nicht gesehen
ich habe also nächsten baum gesehen und
ich dachte so ich werde noch irgendwie
am schlafen oder irgendwie verkatert
oder so als ich das gesehen habe dachte
ich so kann ich irgendwie weg das ist
aber zeit was ist würde und damit helfen
wir können aus gerade das heißt wer war
auch gerade am party machen ja cool dann
habt ihr euch ja praktisch bin und das
partymachen kennengelernt
na gut da muss ich ganz klar sagen dass
vettel geht auf jeden fall an dich ich
habe sie auch schon vorausgesagt
praktisch dass ich gar keine chance habe
zu gewinnen warum beides plan hatten ja
aber so sieht es besser aus und ist
weiblich aber das ist klar aber ich bin
ja ganz sicher dass du niemals jemanden
von dem antworten würdest oder trotzdem
eine sache die ich noch sagen muss ich
hab eigentlich am freitag an gesagt ja
es wird ja jetzt keiner mehr antworten
weil wenn man den schreibt ich kann das
ja selber das geht ja immer weiter
weiter weiter nach unten und man hatte
den geschrieben gestern morgen oder vor
gehst oder
eine freundin von mir hat mir gesagt
weil ich jetzt nicht so eine reichweite
habe aber die manche das liegt daran
dass die anfragen jetzt sortiert werden
ach so heißt der hat wahrscheinlich dann
gesehen also ich war dann wahrscheinlich
relativ weit oben was ich dazu jetzt
noch gesagt hätte nicht mal ich sehe bei
installierte nachricht also oder also
ich gucke da jetzt auch nicht so oft
rein aber dann der der nochmal so noch
viel größere reichweite hat dass der das
dann sieht auch selbst nach dem filter
bin ich schon krass also das ist für
mich dann schon so ein punkt so dass man
auch wirklich danach suchen welche
mädels ein jetzt so geschrieben haben
ähnlich wie bei unserem rapper freund
von anfang ich glaube irgendwie wird es
bei ihnen direkt angezeigt aber ich
wüsste nicht wieso aber ich habe ja
nicht mit dem geschrieben oder so was
ich meine ja der war wahrscheinlich
genau zufällig gerade an seinem
installiert okay leute das war's mit dem
video ich hoffe durch all das macht sich
uninteressant wenn man so schnell du
hast ja ruhig mal zwei tage zeit lassen
können
hockeyfans infos hier einbindet und wir
sehen uns morgen wieder 19 uhr jeden tag
gibt es um 19 uhr neues video das ende
war es ein bisschen chaotisch aber ist
ein